donc c'est un curé un imam un bac sont
d'un avion qui s'écrase ya pas de
parachute
les mecs is ok bon c'est le jugement
dernier c'est le moment de tester notre
foi on va sauter dans le vide et comme
on a servi de moduler nos prophètes
toute l'année normalement on devrait
survivre donc le curé saute et la
seigneur seigneur seigneur seigneur
seigneur celle-ci ces clubs par terre
ils m ont dit mamie ok j'y vais il ya
une grande main immense qui le choque
comme ça qui me dépose tout d une carte
mans sur le sol il est en vie je reçois
les e-bonds c'est à mon tour
il saute renault est un c'est un jeune
fermier qui habite tout seul chez lui
dans sa ferme ses parents sont partis et
il est tout content parce qu'il vient de
recevoir sa toute nouvelle trieuse
portative voyez c'est une petite
trayeuse comme ça tu prends ta trayeuse
tu vas dans le pré ça t'évite de rentrer
et eva je gagne un temps fou donc il est
avec le technicien qui lui montrent les
2/3 bouton edit ça marche tragique on
prive extra il paraît que ça trieuse il
amène sa très les entrées la met sur un
petit tabouret il va chercher une de ses
meilleures vaches
il amène lavage qui prend les traits
honte il actionne le bazar et ça démarre
et la vache comme ça dit il touche à
rien trente secondes après la trieuse
s'arrête tout seul avec 10 litres de
lait to shoot crémeux paysan est fait
mais c'est magnifique mais ça c'est
cette vache ça c'est une [ __ ] évoluer
cherche une autre il va chercher une
nouvelle qui ne va pas elle donne
n'écoute pas tenable amènent leurs
vaches il met les crayons il démarre
même chose la vache comme ça c'est
francine lemay qui fait [ __ ] très
après quelques secondes la trieuse
s'arrête 10 litres de lait tout chaud
tout crémeux le paysan est fait mais
c'est magnifique à ça qu'elle creuse et
vit seul évidemment donc
ils forcent habite il se met dans la
réussit l'actionnaire jamais c'est
magnifique il vient dans la trayeuse
extraordinaire et là il essaie de couper
et ça continue ça ne coupe pas étirer ça
c'est ça fait mal à ça quand tu as fini
tu as fini quand tu en prends son gsm il
appelle le technicien et à la précieuse
elle fautif et la casse pâle s'arrête
tout seul après 10 litres
[Applaudissements]
un jeune homme va voir son père lui dit
papa je voudrais sortir ce soir elie non
tu as 16 ans bientôt 17 tu sens pas tout
seul soit ni papa je t'en supplie c'est
samedi
il ya une fête hyper importante laisse
moi sortir dit non et dit s'il te plaît
les trois sorties il dit je vais te
laisser sortir mais à une heure du matin
tu es là et s'il ya une heure du matin
t'es pas là tu vas avoir à faire
sérieusement à moi il dit papa je te
jure à une heure je suis là verdi ok il
est sortir le gosse à une heure du matin
le père attend est le gars sait toujours
pas là deux heures de glace est toujours
pas là trois heures personnes le père
devient fou il tourne en ridicule voir
sa gueule quand il va rentrer 4h 5h 6h à
7h le montrent il y aura avoir une
explication très cr tous les deux il dit
papa j'ai une bonne raison elia web je
serai curieux de l'entendre dès ce soir
j'ai fait l'amour pour la première fois
à bombay qu'es tu veux qu'on en parle tu
vas t'asseoir signé je veux bien qu'on
en parle mais je veux pas m'asseoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]